so right now serious people are upset
about what happened yesterday in
washington they want to figure out
exactly what happened and they want to
know why
it happened but none of the people who
should be asking are asking instead
they're taking the opportunity to mock
the people
who were there because they're from the
wrong social class
as events unfolded yesterday one cnn
anchor who by the way is a son of a
vanderbilt which is relevant you may
have blue jeans
made it explicit trump supporters are
bad
because they eat at lowbrow restaurants
look at them they're high fiving each
other for this deplorable display
of completely unpatriotic
completely against law and order
completely
unconstitutional behavior it's stunning
and they're going to go back
you know to the olive garden and to
their the holiday inn that they're
staying at in the garden marriott
and they're going to have some drinks
and they're going to talk about the
great day that they had in washington
and they really did something and stand
up for something
and they stood up for nothing other than
mayhem
it's just class war by another name and
never has it been more clear than in
that clip by the way how much do you
appreciate the lecture on
patriotism and law and order from cnn
did you appreciate that hope so
but the point is there are two standards
one that applies to you and the other
that applies to the pasty pink haired
antifa riders they can do whatever they
want
they of course will go back to sag
harbor at the end of the day and stay
with their parents it's totally fine but
trump's supporters
they're insurrectionists they should be
hunted down today cnn unveiled a
soviet-style enemies list to make it a
little easier to find all those trump
supporters
and then destroy them and next we will
roll the tape
on all of the president's enablers who
were all helped
to who have all helped to fuel the
deadly insurrection
at the u.s capitol man that is a jeff
zucker order if there ever was one we
don't have the tape of the morning call
this morning unfortunately